sam karmann qui nous fait donc le
plaisir ce soir de nous accompagner on
va parler de tout d'abord de votre
action de parrain de l'association
agissez contre la violence morale la
présidente et fondatrice de cette
association à maurepas est avec nous on
va commencer par un micro trottoir que
pensez vous de ces personnalités qui
soutiennent des associations c'est notre
question du jour
je n'ai rien contre au compteur si il ya
des certaines personnalités qui peuvent
disons apporter un plus et leur
célébrité ça peut être un plus pour les
certaines associations
moi je pense que ça aide moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est une association mais c'est
toujours pour aider dans un sens ou dans
un autre
donc moi je trouve que c'est pas mal je
trouve que c'est bien ce qu'il faut pas
que tu as connu
peut-être quand même pas forcément en
cause de ce qu'il dit c'est ça permet de
découvrir de nouvelles accusations si
c'est un nom peu moi je vois là
l'association l'arche avec jean jacques
goldman je ne connaissais pas du tout je
te dirai peut-être plus facilement à son
association le fait qu'il en parlera par
son biais le fait que des personnalités
aide des associations c'est
véritablement un plus on peut en parler
pour votre association qui existe depuis
1999 à maurepas agissez contre la
violence morale intrafamiliales et le
stocking oui je pense que c'est
nécessaire parce que c'est un c'est un
relais
c'est un relais médiatiques c'est un
relais qui en impose un petit peu
effectivement donc oui oui voyez moi je
crois que c'est important
comment vous la vivez cette mission
justement bon je veux simplement quand
même dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont moi je salue surtout le travail de
chantal parce que ma position par un
c'est que quand on me donne la parole
bien sûr mon public je l'apprends et
ombres
on est là pour parler de son association
mais mais cet engagement que chantal a
depuis des années elle a réussi à faire
une chose absolument formidable à les
parties vraiment avec rien avec une tout
seul avec son sac à dos et d'année en
année je voyais les mâles qu'elle me
calme envoyée elle me tenait au courant
de l'évolution des choses et maintenant
vraiment allées sont à jc après a pris
de l'importance
il ya des cases des roses et puis il ya
une action concrète c'est pas simplement
parler des gens parce que derrière
derrière le discours il ya des gens en
détresse
et voilà et ben maintenant ces gens en
détresse il elles savent qu'elle peut
pousser la porte il ya un numéro
téléphone ya une adresse et elles sont
reçues
mais comment ça traduit votre soutien
justement ces moments délicats cette
association soutient scialytique par
exemple mon soutien c'est de dire que
par exemple le mi mars
le nude mars c'est la journée de la
femme on a décidé que enfin ils cette
action du gouvernement qui fait que 365
jours moi j'ai pris j'ai pris rendez
vous pour le 3 avril puisque je savais
que j'avais une rencontre publique le 3
avril
on en parlera tout à l'heure et à la fin
de cette rencontre publique qui est une
représentation théâtrale par exemple je
vais m'adresser avec marie-anne chazel
on va parler de la violence faite aux
femmes et toutes les formes de violence
et notamment aussi de la violence morale
et de l'ajc je me suis ressourcé votre
actualité à cette cause pour la faire
connaître à un petit module on fera un
petit module vidéo qu'on mettra qu'on va
mettre dans dans ce calendrier
interactif du ministère voilà ça mais ça
c'est c'est le ministère qui permet ça
donc on le fait mais mais mon action
c'est aussi mais même à dîner entre amis
tout d'un deux parades de padt
c'est cette notion de pervers
narcissique
c'est une notion il ya quelques années
encore dix ans personne n'en parlait
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc c'est
quoi c'est quoi et puis bah voilà le
stocking sais c'est chantal qui en parle
et on commença à dénouer le fil de ses
victimes qui viennent qui se met qu'ici
c'est une violence énorme ça mène au
suicide ça mène à la déstructuration
complète de la vie sociale de la vie
affective c'est des gens en morceaux
contient avec des des pervers
narcissique qui sont très très très
adroit à quattre
il faut savoir les débusquer il faut
voilà donc cette association parle de
tout ça et c'est une pour moi c'était
nouveau et samassa m'a parlé comment
vous avez fait le choix de sam karmann
je reconnais c'est parce que c'est un
voisin et c'est un ami et c'est vrai que
quand on a commencé à se dire qu' il
fallait qu effectivement on est une
personnalité qui puisse
occasionnellement par les noubas je lui
ai fait la proposition en plus je
trouvais que ses films même si ça me
parle pas de violence morale à
proprement parler il y avait des choses
voilà il existait un support et puis 2-2
par sa personne je me disais voilà s'il
accepte ce serait ça serait sympathique
donc il a accepté
pratiquement tout de suite maintenant
après c'est vrai que mettre en place des
actions pour parler de l'association ne
s'est jamais vraiment évident donc il
faut des actualités il faut des choses
le rôle d'un pareils il est un peu floue
et vous avez certaines portes peut-être
vous évoquez tout à l'heure le 8 mars
vous étiez présent donc pour cette
réunion les associations sur marie vous
avez accompagné d'ailleurs chantal sur
ce rendez mais qu'ils avaient l'occasion
d'en parler puisque vous étiez venu nous
voir juste avant ça vous permet
justement de rencontrer des personnes de
défendre votre cause d'obtenir aussi
parfois des financements peut-être parce
que c'était pour vous
ça monte ça amène une certaine caution
et c'est vrai que quand on regarde un
cahier de presse nous dossier de presse
d'annoncé d'écouté oui voilà exactement
ça donne une petite crédit de
crédibilité supplémentaire mais en même
temps c'est bon voilà c'est un tout
c'est vraiment il ya des choses que j'ai
cette cochet s'est de fait je n'ai pas
réussi tout simplement moi j'ai essayé
d'avoir je me souviens une émission où
il y avait un jeu vous savez ces
émissions jeu où on peut doter et et on
reverse à des associations
j'ai essayé j'ai été à deux doigts de le
faire demain ça a failli se faire pire
dernier moment non mais voilà donc il ya
ce qu'ont réussi à faire puis surtout
beaucoup de choses qu'on ne réussit pas
à faire mais ça c'est la loi de de
beaucoup d'associations et beaucoup de
parents qui sont à la violence morale
c'est une question qui vous touche
particulièrement est ce que vous êtes
particulièrement sensible
tous les cas chantal m'en a parlé de
telle sorte qu'elle m'a sensibilisé
parce qu'elle connaît très très bien
très bien la question et depuis je dois
dire
depuis j'ai appris à repérer ou autour
de nous tout d'un coup dans des
histoires on a tous des démons des
couples les vies changent les couples se
séparent et puis parfait dispartion
heureusement qui se passe très très bien
voilà c'est des gens adultes
responsables qui sépare et tout va bien
et puis parfois ça prend des tournures
très très très très très dramatique
et là tout d'un coup justement le fait
d'avoir été avertis de ces choses là où
on a une oreille un petit peu différent
regard un petit peu différent et
peut-être qu'on peut conseiller aussi
dans nos sphères privées on a voilà
c'est quelque chose d'assez répandue
alors heureusement le niveau de violence
est aussi extrêmement variable cela va
de la petite à la plus grande mais bon
dans tous les cas le plus difficile de
votre travail de le déceler on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler il existe un
livre aussi édité récemment je le
rappelle on vend revoir la couverture la
violence morale au quotidien des mots
sont bleues des mots qui tuent et vous
évoquer cette question merci encore à
vous on va afficher aussi une nouvelle
fois les coordonnées un contact site
internet numéro de téléphone pour ceux
qui voudraient en savoir plus ou qui
voudraient tout simplement vous
arte qui auraient besoin de votre aide
merci chantal paoli le texier merci à
vous sam karmann vous restez en plateau
avec nous on parle de votre actualité à
présent